[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 los diputados franceses debaten una
polémica ley contra lo que se ha llamado
el separatismo islamista el objetivo es
luchar contra la radicalización después
de los atentados de los últimos meses
como la decapitación de un maestro en
las afueras de parís o el ataque contra
una iglesia en niza y para hablarnos de
todo ello tenemos en línea al
investigador musa bureba muchísimas
gracias musa y bienvenido
gracias a ustedes francés de aviñón y
actualmente reside en barcelona en
españa donde es profesor e investigador
e investigador en el cinta han sido para
el centro de barcelona de asuntos
internacionales es especialista en
procesos de radicalización y en
estrategias para prevenir la
radicalización esta ley se llama
oficialmente así lo hemos traducido en
español ley que refuerza los principios
de la red pública
francia es uno de los países más
afectados por atentados yihadistas en
europa recordemos el fatídico año 2015
con los atentados de enero contra el
semanario satírico charlie hebdo el
supermercado judío y luego los atentados
en las terrazas el estadio de francia y
la sala de conciertos bataclán
prácticamente todos los autores de los
ataques eran franceses o europeos
este proyecto incluye 50 artículos para
restringir por ejemplo la escolarización
en casa de niños mayor control sobre el
funcionamiento y financiación
de las mezquitas y de sus imanes y
dotarse de instrumentos para luchar
contra los mensajes de odio en las redes
sociales en internet según usted mu
sauret va esta ley será eficaz para
luchar contra la radicalización o contra
o para evitar que se produzcan ataques
terroristas
no sé hasta qué punto será eficaz esta
ley quiero recordar aquí que desde los
afectados de charly ya ha adoptado tres
planes de prevención de la
radicalización entonces al mirar en el
detalle este proyecto de ley de las
propuestas que acaba de mencionar no sé
hasta qué punto el controlar las
mezquitas o la escolarización de los
niños permite prevenir la radicalización
o añade a aquellos aquellos planes de
prevención de la radicalización que las
autoridades francesas y adoptaron cuando
miramos cómo vivían en el detalle se
centra esta ley se detecta más
específicamente sobre determinadas
prácticas religiosas rigoristas que se
consideran problemáticas entonces en
luchar contra estas prácticas
frigoristas no sé hasta qué punto puede
contribuir a hacer de la radicación
y la idea un poco subyacente que tiene
este proyecto de ley es que a más
práctica religiosa más riesgo pero vista
y yo creo que no sólo es erróneo que se
sustenta en ningún tipo de evidencia
empírica sino que puede ser peligroso ya
pero por ejemplo uno de los puntos
esenciales es la financiación de los
centros de culto como las mezquitas o
las asociaciones musulmanas que en
ocasiones reciben dinero del exterior
hay algunas salafistas que han sido
investigadas por ejemplo la de pantalla
en el norte de parís
que parte de responsabilidad tienen
ciertas mezquitas o ciertos imanes en la
radicalización de jóvenes franceses
yo creo que en algunos casos es verdad
que determinadas mezquitas o
determinadas asociaciones jugaron un
papel a la hora de radicalizar a
determinados individuos no por ejemplo
los hermanos cuasi o algún miembro de
los autores de los atentados del 13 de
noviembre de 2015
ahí sí que las mezquitas jugaron un
papel o algunos líderes carismáticos
pero lo que vemos desde la investigación
es que la radicalización ocurre cada vez
menos en las mezquitas ocurre
esencialmente fuera de las mezquitas en
domicilios privados
durante actividades de ocio o en canales
de telegrama es cierto que hay que
controlar los sistemas como la
financiación de determinadas mezquitas o
asociaciones pero todo otra vez cuando
vemos la magnitud de los procesos de los
procesos de radicalización que tienen
lugar fuera de las mezquitas no sé hasta
qué punto una medida de este tipo
contribuirá a prevenir la erradicación
sería tal vez
tendría que hacer tal vez más hincapié
en internet en las redes sociales
seguramente se tendrá que hacer más
hincapié y yo creo que los esfuerzos
tanto de las autoridades como incluso
desde el ámbito de la investigación se
estudia hasta qué punto las redes
sociales
determinarán determinadas plataformas
determinados foros juegan un papel y aún
así la radicalización suele tener lugar
esencialmente offline es decir
físicamente y no sólo en las redes
entonces estamos ante un fenómeno ante
el cual digamos que no hay una solución
única o una receta mágica hay que actuar
sobre distintos canales que la favorecen
en este sentido creo que sería quizás
presuntuoso pensar que al actuar sobre
solo un canal o sólo un factor
podemos solucionar el problema es más
bien hace falta tener una conservación
holística del tema menos
en francia hay 6 millones de musulmanes
es un cálculo porque está oficialmente
prohibido hacer estadísticas por
religiones porque aquí se practican la
religión libremente y no hay un control
algunos creen que con esta ley se va a
estigmatizar a los musulmanes pero
justamente muchos musulmanes están
pidiendo que se tomen medidas para
proteger a sus hijos de la
radicalización qué opina usted
yo creo que los musulmanes en francia al
igual que los musulmanes en francia
tienen temen por la radical sección de
sus hijos y creo también que los
musulmanes en francia temen por las
consecuencias de algunas medidas se
toman para prevenirla
en concreto e insisto en que este
proyecto de ley lo que viene a asumir es
que algunas prácticas religiosas
conducen a la radicalización y yo repito
que esto no es cierto se comprueba en
algunos casos pero en la mayoría de los
casos no está sucediendo entonces
sabiendo esto conviene preguntarse hasta
qué punto este tipo de medidas generan
más consecuencias contraproducentes y
qué consecuencias digamos positivas en
el marco de la lucha contra contra la
radicarse pero entonces diría que existe
esta inquietud pero que al querer
reprimir prácticas como la mutilación
quitan por el matrimonio forzado que son
condenables evidentemente desde un punto
de vista moral
creo que esto tenga algo que ver con con
la lucha contra la radicalización y de
hecho los debates que estamos viendo en
la asamblea nacional
en francia han tratado esencialmente de
velo de velo y de velo y yo no sé hasta
qué punto el llevar el pañuelo por
ejemplo es un factor de radicalización
entonces me da la sensación un poco de
que la lucha contra la rehabilitación es
un pretexto para que las autoridades
vigilen control en algunas prácticas que
desde el punto de vista digamos de la
convivencia son problemáticas pero que
no hay que tratar desde el prisma de
lanting de la lucha antiterrorista creo
que es extremadamente peligroso en la
laicidad que es la separación de la
iglesia el estado y la libertad de culto
y bueno en las reglas de la república
están encima de la religión esto es la
laicidad y el respeto de las religiones
pero por ejemplo el hecho de poder
criticar las religiones aquí en francia
no existe el delito de blasfemia puesto
que no se puede transformar porque hay
libertad para y no se consideran un
delito en hay libertad de prensa
libertad de expresión pero parece que
cada vez está más en peligro no sé si es
su opinión también pero la gente que
publica este tipo de caricaturas como
las de charlie hebdo pone en riesgo su
vida lo vimos con el profesor patinó que
fue decapitado en las afueras de parís
está en peligro esa libertad de
expresión en en francia
yo creo que digamos que si hablamos de
libertad de expresión yo creo que hay
determinadas reacciones como cómo está
este este acto de terrorismo
absolutamente atroz
que demuestra que existen problemas con
la libertad de expresión
esto no lo niego pero tampoco creo que
la laicidad se debería reducir
simplemente a la libertad de expresión
en muchas instancias equiparamos con el
derecho a la paz en el derecho
el hecho de las geniales un derecho y
creo que esto es una garantía
es muy importante que trae la electridad
por tanto diría que si efectivamente
existen reacciones que vienen a poner en
peligro esta libertad de expresión que
hay que luchar contra y así hay que
condenar estas reacciones pero creo que
no deberíamos reducir lo que es la
equidad como principio normativo de
separación del estado de la religión con
la libertad de expresión creo que es
algo mucho más global y creo que este
parto el de la vez que al día de hoy sí
que está en peligro hay muchas
inquietudes últimamente porque parece
que está resurgiendo el estado islámico
en siria y en irak hace pocas semanas da
es perpetró un doble ataque suicida en
bagdad cuál es la situación está
resurgiendo sigue teniendo fuerza da es
pues sigue teniendo fuerza como lo
demuestran aquellos atentados terribles
que pudieron en bagdad hace pocos días a
estado islámico sigue presente desde más
de una docena de países
desde manía hasta hasta filipinas
de hecho se considera que cuenta con
unas 30.000 personas que lo defienden
activamente no en todos estos países
sigue siendo una amenaza esto si los
atentados y el atentado que ocurrió en
viena demuestra que sigue siendo una
amenaza incluso para europa y no sólo
para los países en los que se encuentra
físicamente en este sentido me gustaría
subrayar que el fin estado islámico como
protestado en absoluto ha implicado en
el fin de la organización estado
islámico está el islámico empezado como
una organización terrorista
lan destina y desde que se acabó este
pseudo califato pues está volviendo a
ello es decir algo en el que siempre han
sido
fuertes de alguna forma expanderse de
atacar de ataques terroristas y cuál es
el grado de amenaza en europa y células
durmientes que pueden atacar en
cualquier momento
no sé en concreto cuál es el grado de
amenaza pero lo que sí está cierto es
que muchos países gracias por ellos
-españa bélgica alemania ya que en la
mayoría de países al menos de europa
occidental los niveles de alerta
antiterrorista son muy altos entre 4 y 5
sobre 5
kaia células durmientes seguramente las
hay
de hecho si vemos para el caso de
francia desde el 2017 se ha frustrado a
un atentado cada mes entonces existen
aún células o individuos por la voluntad
de perpetrar atentados terroristas bueno
pues ya no nos queda más tiempo
muchísimas gracias musa bureba
investigador y especialista en islamismo
radical en europa del instituto de
análisis y dop en barcelona en españa'
muchísimas gracias por todo este
análisis y muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes por habernos acompañado ya saben
que nos pueden seguir por internet en rf
y mundo.com bien france24 puntocom hasta
[Música]